.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Mein erster Eindruck war:
"Fantastisch."
"Genau wie erwartet."
Ich dachte nur:
"Mein Gott, ist der gross."
Ja, das hast du mir gesagt.
Wir fühlten uns beide
so angezogen vom anderen
und fanden den anderen
attraktiv und sympathisch.
Es stimmte einfach alles.
Obwohl beide im Hinterkopf dachten,
das würde nicht funktionieren.
Ich war gar nicht so lange verliebt.
Es ging schnell schon viel tiefer.
Als wären wir
schon viel länger zusammen.
Für mich.
- Ja.
Und so zogen wir schnell zusammen.
Als Monica Peter Artawan
vor 14 Jahren
auf die Götterinsel Bali auswanderte,
war sie überzeugter Single.
Doch dann lernte sie Dewa kennen
und alles kam ganz anders.
Good boy.
- Come.
Zwei Länder, eine Liebe:
Das ist "Hin und weg".
* Romantische Ballade *
Dewa ist mein jodoh, mein soulmate.
Also, mein Seelenverwandter.
Ich fühle mich einfach extrem wohl.
Von A bis Z.
Er ist mein Ruhepol.
Ich bin eher impulsiv
und er ist mein Ruhepol.
Ja.
Eigentlich liebe ich alles an ihm.
Als ich meine Frau
zum ersten Mal sah, war ich nervös.
Was konnte ich tun?
Ich sprach nicht gut Englisch.
Aber ich blieb dran,
langsam und behutsam.
Nur Lächeln. So war das.
Doggy, come. Nein, nein, nein.
Das Paar lebt im Süden Balis.
Monica ist 58, Dewa 38 Jahre alt.
Die beiden Hunde Lucky und Spike
sind ihr Ein und Alles
und halten sie auf Trab.
Spike? Oh.
Good boy. Yes. Good boy.
Good boy.
Die Sauce warm machen ...
Das ist das Frühstück für die Hunde.
Wir machen ihnen
einmal pro Woche ein Poulet.
Wir kaufen es frisch vom Markt
und dann wird es gekocht.
Der Sud ...
... wird im Kühlschrank halt hart.
Den machen wir morgens etwas warm
und mischen ihn unters Essen.
Sodass die Damen und Herren
immer etwas Frisches haben.
* Ein Hahn kräht. *
Lucky?
Spike? Come. Makan, makan.
Makan, makan.
Spike, hey. Spike.
- Lucky, come.
Lucky, come.
Come. Ja, good girl.
Monica und Dewa haben die Hunde
gerettet und adoptiert.
Oh, heute ist es aber schlimm. So.
Sie sind eigentlich Familie für uns.
Wir haben ja keine Kinder.
Wir haben
einen Zusammenhalt mit ihnen
und das gibt Leben im Haus.
Wir haben auch
extrem viele schöne Erlebnisse.
Gerade am Strand
oder wenn wir sonst wo hingehen.
Sie bedeuten uns sehr viel.
Wir mögen sie sehr.
Der Tag
beginnt um 5.30 Uhr morgens.
Dann ist es noch angenehm kühl.
Für das gemeinsame Frühstück
nehmen sie sich Zeit.
Das ist meine absolute
Lieblingsfrucht am Morgen: Papaya.
Eine reife Papaya.
Die ist super für die Verdauung
und einfach lecker.
In der Schweiz war das ganz anders:
Da gab es einen Espresso
und auf dem Weg zum Tram
einen Snack.
Aber das ist hier
ein wichtiger Bestandteil des Tags.
Wenn es so heiss ist
und man nichts im Magen hat,
wird es einem relativ schnell
schwindlig.
Dewa ist Koch,
hat aber auch schon als Personal
Trainer und Bodyguard gearbeitet.
Sein Hobby ist Bodybuilding.
I love it.
Monica ist selbstständig
und als Interior Designerin tätig.
Jetzt bauen sie
und machen ein neues Haus neben uns.
Kann sein.
- Ja.
Die letzten Jahre haben
die beiden in der Schweiz verbracht.
Darum
versteht Dewa etwas Schweizerdeutsch.
Bahasa Indonesia
ist ein grosser Teil und Englisch.
Das ist unser Mix.
Aber es mischen sich immer wieder
schweizerdeutsche Happen ein.
Ich verstehe viel,
aber kann nicht gut sprechen.
Aber es gefällt mir gut.
Darum ist das bei uns ein Canpuran,
ein Mix.
Oder?
Wir waren und sind beide
in der Eiskunstlaufszene tätig.
Ich kenne Romain
seit über 20 Jahren.
So lange weiss ich,
dass es ihn gibt.
Eine meiner Nachwuchssportlerinnen
sagte
bei einem Wettkampf in Rumänien:
"Oh Romain, der schönste
Eiskunstläufer heisst Jamal Othman."
"Er ist Schweizer."
Und ja, er gefiel mir.
Er sieht zwar
nicht sehr schweizerisch aus,
aber es stimmt: Er ist schön.
Montreal.
Seit acht Jahren
ist die kanadische Stadt
das Zuhause von Jamal und Romain.
Jamal Othman
wuchs in Münchenbuchsee auf.
Seine Mutter ist Schweizerin,
sein Vater stammt aus Malaysia.
Fünf Jahre lebte er in Asien,
bevor er hierherzog.
Alors, stretch your leg.
Stretch and rise up.
Der Franzose Romain Haguenauer
gehört zu den international
erfolgreichsten Eiskunstlauftrainern.
Die beiden
sind seit zehn Jahren ein Paar.
And again.
* Aufgestellter Cha-Cha-Cha *
* Applaus *
Er sieht gut aus,
ist erfolgreich, selbstsicher,
aber auch sehr lustig
und wirklich ein Franzose.
Ja, sie haben so eine Aura.
Etwas, das sie ...
Ich weiss nicht,
das ist schwer zu beschreiben.
Das kann einen nerven,
aber ich finde das sehr ...
Ja, ich finde das sehr sexy.
And character. And sometimes ...
So, it's good and smooth,
but give me some accents, please.
Okay? Allez.
* Energetische Musik *
Als Romain Jamal traf,
war er hin und weg - insgeheim.
Ja, das war wohl so,
aber ich wollte es nicht zeigen.
Ich bin stolz und ich glaube,
er auch. Aber voilà.
Natürlich gab es da was.
Wir wollten
uns auch schnell wiedersehen.
Damals arbeitete Jamal
als Nationalcoach
in Malaysia und Singapur.
Zuvor war er Profi-Eiskunstläufer.
Nahm an Olympischen Spielen
und Weltmeisterschaften teil.
Da war ich 20. Jesses Gott.
Das ist ein super Gefühl
am Wettkampf,
mit diesen Sprüngen
und dem Wind im Gesicht ...
Nein, das war unglaublich schön.
* Energetische Musik *
Es ist schon lange her,
seit ich aufgehört habe.
Das ist schon über 13 Jahre her.
Ich hörte auf, weil ich fand,
dass ich erreicht hatte, was ich
erreichen kann in meiner Karriere.
Ich hatte
auch gesundheitliche Probleme.
Ich hatte vier Operationen
an den Füssen und Rückenprobleme.
Für mich war klar,
dass ich studieren und
die nächste Karriere starten wollte.
Das Leben geht weiter,
nachdem man Sport gemacht hat. Ja.
Glaubst du, die Chance ist gross,
dass Jean-Luc in Graz dabei ist?
Wieso?
- Weil er das gesagt hat.
Der 37-Jährige kommentiert noch immer
Eiskunstlaufübertragungen für SRF
und er ist Geschäftsführer
der Ice-Academy.
Zuvor führten die beiden
eine Fernbeziehung.
Jamal
konnte es sich manchmal einrichten,
mich in Japan, China oder Lyon
zu treffen.
Oder
wir machten Ferien in Südostasien.
Das war eine sehr glückliche Zeit
in meinem Leben.
Alles war gut:
Ich hatte Jamal -
zwar am andern Ende der Welt,
aber wir waren uns sehr nah.
Hop.
Jam, bist du fertig?
Nach zwei Jahren
zogen sie in Montreal zusammen.
C'est le vert là-bas.
Am Morgen um 7 Uhr ...
- Ja.
... tranken wir einen Kaffee
in einem Warung,
mitten in einem Reisfeld
oben an Ubud.
Danach kam Dewa zu mir an den Tisch.
Wir waren ein Rudel an Leuten.
Er brachte mir
eine kleine Wiesenblume.
Ja.
- Und er lachte so.
Das war ein magic moment.
- Ja.
Ich sagte nichts.
Ich schenkte sie ihr und
von da an war sie in meinem Herzen.
Für immer.
* Neugierige Musik *
Let's go.
Monica und Dewa
haben einen gemeinsamen Traum:
Auf diesem Reisfeld
soll eine Plantage
für Naturheilkräuter entstehen.
Bis es so weit ist,
überlassen sie die 2'300 m2
den Bauern als Leihgabe.
Alles ist grün. Hier sind wir.
Sie haben den Reis schon geerntet.
Alles ist geschnitten.
Ja.
So sieht das aus. Schön, gell?
- Schön, ja. Alles grün.
Noch ist das Projekt erst eine Idee,
aber Dewa hat schon viel Vorwissen.
Gibt es noch andere Kräuter,
die wir brauchen könnten?
Diese Blume hier.
This flower.
- Show me.
Oh, this one.
- This one.
That's the new one.
Dewa, what is the name of that one?
Das ist Mitir.
- Mitir?
There are many kinds of Mitir.
- Yes.
Sie ist gut für die äusserliche
Anwendung beim Bauch.- Outside?
Yeah. With oil.
- To mix with oil?
Man mischt es mit Öl und reibt es
dann so zusammen ein.- Yeah.
Was haben wir noch?
Den beiden schwebt ein Zentrum
für ganzheitliche Gesundheit vor.
Das hier ist Pakis,
man kann es als Gemüse essen.
Meine Familie
gab mir ihr Wissen früh weiter.
Sie arbeitete auf dem Reisfeld und
mein Grossvater erklärte mir alles.
Mein Kakek.
- Ist das dein Grossvater?
Ja.
Mein Grossvater
explained everything.
Was ist das?
Uraltes Wissen weitergeben
und gleichzeitig
ein gemeinsames Business aufbauen -
noch ist das erst eine Vision.
Es musste einfach passieren.
- Schicksal. Ja.
Als wir
in Jönköping auf den Markt gingen,
sagte ein älterer Schwede zu uns:
"Wieso in aller Welt
legst du den langen Weg
in die Schweiz zurück,
um eine Frau zu finden?"
"Schweden ist doch voll von ihnen."
Ich hatte keine gute Antwort,
es passierte einfach.
Die ist schwer.
Wiedersehen
mit Florence und Niklas Wibring.
"Hin und weg" hat sie
während ihrer dreijährigen
Fernbeziehung begleitet.
Heute beginnt für das Ehepaar
ein neuer Lebensabschnitt.
Du hast viel zu viel Krempel.
That's a fact.
Aber du bist mein Held.
Du schaffst das.
Ja, und ich bin auch Zauberer -
ich verdopple den Stauraum.
Ja,
dein Name ist Niklas Copperfield.
Florence
zieht zu Niklas nach Schweden.
Ihr Wunsch geht in Erfüllung.
Waschpulver.
Okay.
Es gibt auch Waschpulver
in Schweden.
Nora, du kannst
noch nicht einsteigen. Warte.
Florence hat nicht nur ein Flair
für Möbel, sondern auch für Hunde.
Neun Stück müssen mit.
Ich reise zum ersten Mal
mit 300 Hunden.
It's the first time.
- 253.
Okay.
Sag Jasmin Tschüss.
Die 51-Jährige
ist passionierte Tierschützerin.
Alle ihre Hunde hat sie
aus erbärmlichen Umständen gerettet.
So.
Komm.
Dann warte du auch noch schnell.
Henry darf im Cockpit mitfahren.
Vor drei Jahren sprachen wir
darüber, wie der Tag sein wird.
Und jetzt ist er hier.
Das ist schon ...
Ja ... Es ist ganz anders.
Man fragt sich auch,
wie wir miteinander umgehen.
Wir lebten bis jetzt
in einer Fernbeziehung.
Und jetzt sind wir am gleichen Ort.
Florence muss ihre beiden Töchter
in der Schweiz zurücklassen.
Die jüngere
wohnte bis vor Kurzem noch zu Hause.
Ich habe Pizza bestellt.
- Das reicht nicht.
Der Abschied von Noya fällt schwer.
Sie brauchte
besonders viel Zuwendung.
Ja, ja. Hi.
* Lachen *
Hi.
- Hi.
Schön, dich zu sehen.
Wir haben noch Werkzeuge für dich.
Du bist jetzt auf dich gestellt.
Es hat Verlängerungskabel.
- Ja, ja.
Zubehör. Einen Hammer ...
Alles Mögliche.- Okay.
Thanks.
Noya hatte psychische Probleme,
mit Angststörungen und Panikattacken.
Künftig wird sich die Grossmutter
um sie kümmern.
Ruf an, wenn etwas ist. Okay?
- Mhm. Ja.
Grosi und Nina kümmern sich um dich.
Gehst du schon wieder arbeiten?
- Ja.
Hast du was gegessen?
- Nein.
Tschüss.
Was tut dir leid?
- Dass ich dich alleine lasse.
Mom, du hast ein eigenes Leben.
Ich bin nicht mehr zehn.
* Lautes Bellen *
Du musst Henry noch Tschüss sagen.
- Nein.
Ich auch nicht.
- Also: tschüss.
Bye-bye.
- Bye.
Wir sind bei dir,
am Telefon und im Herzen.
Okay?
- Love you. Bye.
Bye.
Okay.
Machen wir weiter.
Puh.
Tschüss.
Kein Blödsinn. Habe Gott vor Augen.
- Ja.
Weil Noya Flugangst hat, befürchtet
Florence eine längere Trennung.
Du wirst okay sein, sie auch.
Sie ist schon gross.
Alles andere ist okay, aber sie
zurückzulassen tut am meisten weh.
It hurts the most.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf.
Mit etwas Glück haben wir alle.
Es ist gut so.
- Es ist perfekt.
Ich habe mega Respekt vor der Fahrt.
Ich hoffe, dass alles gut geht,
dass wir keinen Unfall haben.
Das ist immer ...
... was einem
am meisten Respekt macht.
Einfach in Bezug auf die Fahrt.
Und sonst habe ich Angst vor
den Emotionen, die kommen werden.
Wahrscheinlich.
Ja, sie kommen jetzt schon.
Ja.
Hallo, Würstchen. Bereit?
Autopilot ein, Klappen ausgefahren -
los geht's.
Ah.
1'600 km liegen zwischen Derendingen
und ihrem neuen Leben in Schweden.
Ehemann und Ehemann - fast hätte ich
"Ehemann und Ehefrau" gesagt.
Das hat etwas Offizielles,
auch vor dem Gesetz.
Es ist verbindlich
und eine zusätzliche Bekräftigung.
Das war an einem Punkt
in unserer Beziehung,
als wir das auch brauchten.
Und ...
Wir mussten rausfinden, dass wir
beide das bis ans Lebensende wollen.
* Entspannte Musik *
Vor sechs Jahren haben sich Jamal
und Romain das Jawort gegeben.
Wie jung du warst.
Das war noch früh am Abend.
Erinnerst du dich?
Ich habe dich noch nicht gefragt.
Du hast noch nicht
mit dem Schlimmsten gerechnet.
Wir waren 2016 in Malaysia,
in Kuala Lumpur in den Ferien
und feierten dort Silvester.
Das war wirklich lustig.
Romain stand irgendwann auf
und sagte einfach,
wie schön er es finde, dass
all meine alten Freunde da seien
und er sie
wieder mal sehen könne usw.
Eine superschöne Speech.
Ich kapierte es immer noch nicht.
Ich kapierte es erst,
als er die Box öffnete
und fragte,
ob ich ihn heiraten wolle.
Er ging nicht auf die Knie.
Ja.
Natürlich sagte ich dann Ja.
Und dann haben wir Party gemacht.
Es war Dezember.
Ich war bei meiner Familie
in Lyon in Frankreich.
Jamal
war in der Schweiz über Weihnachten.
Wir feierten nicht zusammen.
Ich kam später nach.
Wir hatten Krieg.
Wir hatten
eine kleine Auseinandersetzung,
weil ich
nicht rechtzeitig zugesagt hatte.
Ich hatte schlecht geplant.
Damals war ich
noch nicht so schweizerisch.
Nichts Schlimmes.
Ich war auf der Suche
nach einem Weihnachtsgeschenk.
Ich war unterwegs und dachte:
"Das habe ich ihm schon gekauft,
eine Tasche hat er schon ..."
Dann kam ich
an einer Bijouterie vorbei.
Und ich dachte:
"Schmuck - wieso nicht?"
Und einfach so: "Wieso nicht
einen Ring und einen Heiratsantrag?"
Die Idee kam, weil ich
noch kein Weihnachtsgeschenk hatte.
Ein halbes Jahr später läuteten
in Montreal die Hochzeitsglocken.
Das ist wie bei uns im Standesamt:
Alle 30 Min.
wird jemand verheiratet.
Aber hier hat es wie beim Flughafen
einen Security Check unten.
Wir standen alle draussen
und bis wir wirklich drin waren,
waren wir zu spät.
Wir mussten den Gurt ausziehen,
die Schuhe ...
Ich dachte:
"Das schaffen wir nie mit allen."
Es war dann
eine halbe Stunde später.
Aber wir hatten es lustig.
Ich liebe solche Missgeschicke.
Und ja, beim Ehegelübde
wurden die Gäste emotional.
Gertrud, deine Mutter, machte so:
Wir sind nicht die Superromantiker,
aber es war schon emotional.
Das Lustigste war:
Nach der Trauung mussten wir
den Ausgang links nehmen.
Rechts war angeschrieben:
"Scheidung".- Oui, c'est sûr.
Da weiss man wohin,
falls es nicht funktioniert.
* Entspannte Musik *
Florence, Niklas und die neun Hunde
sind in Südschweden angekommen -
nach 30 Std.
Es fühlt sich wie Ferien an,
die nach zwei Wochen vorbei sind.
I have the same feeling.
- Mit dem Unterschied,
dass wir viele Hunde
und viele Kisten dabeihaben.
Yeah. Wirklich merkwürdig.
Yeah, so weird.
Ausser einer Panne,
eines geplatzten Reifens ...
... ging es
erstaunlicherweise sehr gut.
Auch mit den Hunden.
Es ging megasuper.
Besser als erwartet.
Achtung, ein Frosch.
- Oh shit.
Habe ich ihn erwischt?
- No.
Vorsicht.
Ihr Haus liegt mitten im Wald.
Niklas
hat es eigenhändig für sie gebaut.
Florence sieht es
zum ersten Mal in fertigem Zustand.
Oh my God.
* Knurren *
Henry.
Willkommen zu Hause.
* Sie macht überwältigte Geräusche. *
Oh my God.
Ist es okay für Sie, Madame?
Mehr als okay.
So ...
Wow.
Danke dir.
Vor fünf Jahren haben sich die beiden
auf Facebook kennengelernt.
Die Pandemie
verzögerte das Zusammenziehen.
Wow.
Ich habe es bis jetzt
nur auf Fotos gesehen.
Ich musste
anhand von Fotos auswählen.
Jetzt hierzustehen, ist ...
Also ...
Es erwartet uns noch viel Arbeit,
aber es ist einfach mega.
Es ...
Ja.
Wow.
Wunderschön.
- Wir sind noch nicht fertig.
Nein, aber es ist mir egal.
- Den Rest machen wir zusammen.
Es war ein Superprojekt.
Ein langes Projekt.
Ja.
Ja, ja.
- Céleste du bist die Erste.
Hatten wir immer einen Husky?
* Lachen *
Okay. So. Ja. So, ja.
Ja, Céleste. Céleste.
* Bellen *
Uff.
Die drehen durch.
- Was machen sie?
Sie rennen rum wie die Idioten.
Ah, bald wird es hell.
- Yes.
Wir vertrauen einander 100%ig.
Ich vertraue ihm mein Leben an
und er mir seins.
Es ist eine reife Liebe,
verbindlich und sicher.
Vor eineinhalb Jahren zogen
Jamal Othman und Romain Haguenauer
in eine grosszügige Wohnung im ehe-
maligen Industriequartier Montreals.
Oh ... C'est bon.
- C'est bon?
Oui.
Das passt.
* Ächzen *
Alles auspacken?
- Ja klar.
Mais ...
Bald werden die beiden
mehr Platz brauchen.
Darum wollen sie
das Gästezimmer umfunktionieren.
Ich führe nur aus.
Er liest die Gebrauchsanweisung:
"Gib mir dies, gib mir das."
Jamal ist der Chef.
Warte, das ist befestigt.
Ah, das ist für die Betthöhe.
Je pense que tu le mets en bas.
Wo ist oben und unten?
- Il y a des trous.
In wenigen Wochen wird ihr Leben
komplett auf den Kopf gestellt.
Sag du.
- Ja, wir werden Papis.
Ja, eine grosse Veränderung
in unserem Leben.
Das Projekt
haben wir vor vier Jahren begonnen.
Jetzt wird es konkret:
Wir werden Eltern.
Zwei Väter.
Unser Bébé wird in fünf,
sechs Wochen geboren werden.
Ich habe drei Brüder.
Ich komme aus einer grossen Familie.
Ich habe mir immer vorgestellt,
mal Papi zu werden.
Und jetzt freue ich mich
natürlich unglaublich.
Das ist so.
Ja, das gehört hierhin.
- Il faut le mettre dans le bois.
Hier ist eine Lasche.
- Ah, d'accord.
* Romain summt. *
Hop.
(Beide) Aw.
Am Anfang unserer Beziehung
hat mir Jamal gesagt,
er wollte immer schon ein Kind.
Ich sagte: "Ich auch,
aber ich sehe keine Möglichkeit."
Aber dann haben wir realisiert, dass
es hier in Kanada legal für uns ist,
ein Kind zu kriegen.
Uns hat überzeugt, dass es hier
möglich ist, ein Kind grosszuziehen.
Ich war noch etwas zurückhaltend.
Aber wir wollten alles dafür tun.
Was hat Nana gekauft?
- Oh, das Häschen.
Voilà.
Das ist süss.
- Oui.
Wir stellen ihn vor die grüne Wand.
Moi, je pense que là, c'est bon.
Schön. Non?
Pour l'instant.
* Erwartungsvolle Musik *
Auf Bali ist der Markt
für Koch Dewa ein Schlaraffenland.
Vom kleinen Chili.
Was kaufst du Leckeres?
Ah, Chili Lambek für den Sambal.
Monica und Dewa
haben vor elf Jahren geheiratet.
Weil auf Bali nur Paare
mit demselben Glauben getraut werden,
konvertierte Monica zum Hinduismus.
Seitdem sind Opfergaben für
die Götter Teil des täglichen Gebets.
Das ist, weil ich mich
jetzt auch zum Hinduismus bekenne.
Ich finde das eine sehr schöne ...
Wie soll ich sagen?
Es fehlt mir,
wenn ich es nicht mache.
Ich finde das eine schöne Routine.
Das kannte ich in der Schweiz nicht.
Zuhause ist die Küche Dewas Reich.
Hier ist er im Element.
Meine Mutter
war die beste Köchin auf Bali.
Aber leider
habe ich sie nicht richtig gekannt.
Sie ist sehr früh gestorben.
Wenn ich koche, glaube ich,
dass sie und die Götter
mich inspirieren.
Ich liebe es zu kochen.
Als das Paar nach acht Jahren Bali
in die Schweiz zog,
machte Dewa
eine Tellerwäscherkarriere.
Ich arbeitete als Küchengehilfe.
Ich half überall mit.
So bin aufgestiegen.
Monica war damals
als Marketingfachfrau tätig.
Weil sie und Dewa auf Bali ein
Gesundheitsprojekt umsetzen wollen,
suchte sie nach Investoren.
Dewa
arbeitete in verschiedenen Hotels.
Schliesslich kochte er für ein
renommiertes Restaurant in Zürich.
Das war in der Küche
des Club Baur au Lac.
In the Baur au Lac.
Ich mache das Mise en Place -
hier für eine Ente.
Ja.
Sie fragten mich:
"Kannst du kochen?"
Ich sagte: "Ja."
"Ihr könnt mir das Mise en Place
geben, ich kann helfen."
Es gelang mir sehr gut
und der Chef lobte mich.
Er sagte: "Ich unterstütze dich."
Ich war so glücklich
und dankte den Göttern Balis.
Im Herbst zog es Monica und Dewa
zurück nach Bali.
Beide vermissten die Wärme
und die balinesische Lebensart.
Hier können sie
ein gutes Leben führen.
Wir haben ein Haus hier,
einen Swimmingpool ...
Wir können uns
auch Angestellte leisten.
Es ist auch gut, dass wir die haben.
Wenn wir arbeiten, braucht es
jemanden, der einen unterstützt.
Wir sind hier in den Tropen -
da lebt das Haus sonst.
In der Schweiz hätten wir das nicht.
Dafür bräuchten wir
ein viel höheres Einkommen.
Danke vielmals. Es ist immer
so schön, wenn du kochst.
Viva.
- Cheers.
Guten Appetit.
- Guten Appetit.
* Entspannte Musik *
Am Anfang  f ü h l t e  es
sich stärker an.
Aber jetzt  i s t  es
stärker als zuvor.
Je besser wir uns kennenlernen
und je mehr Zeit
wir zusammen verbringen.
Erst vor wenigen Stunden
sind Florence und Niklas
in Schweden angekommen.
Nach einer kurzen Nacht richten sie
ihr neues, gemeinsames Zuhause ein.
Gut so?
- Gut.
Weiter.
Ich bringe die Schlafzimmerpaneele
ins Schlafzimmer.
Da sollen sie auch hin.
Okay. Ich schaffe das.
2-3 Std. Schlaf. Ja.
Aber es geht erstaunlicherweise gut.
Niklas
hat noch bis um 5.30 Uhr morgens
einen provisorischen Zaun errichtet,
damit wir die Hunde heute rauslassen
können und sie draussen sein können.
Er scheint zu funktionieren:
Es sind noch alle da.
Everyone is still here, yes.
Ich und Würstchen machen Pause.
Mein Kopilot.
* Lachen *
Noch ist die Nähe ungewohnt.
Ich versuche, mich
von der Inneinrichtung fernzuhalten.
Ich trage die falschen Sachen ...
Sie macht die Pläne
und sie ändert sie auch.
But it's okay. It's okay.
Keine Beschwerden.
- Nein.
Niklas
kann sich draussen verwirklichen.
Habt ihr in der Schweiz
diese alten Wasserpumpen?
So pumpt man das Wasser.
Ah, ja, ja, ja.
- To get the water.
Perfekt, oder?
- Okay.
Der Hausbau zog sich hin.
Niklas, der einen Handwerksbetrieb
führt, machte fast alles selbst.
Freunde halfen ihm.
Ich glaube,
ich habe meine Freunde noch.
Aber ich
verbrachte sehr viele Stunden hier.
An die 2'000 vielleicht.
Gleichzeitig
arbeitete ich in meiner Firma,
Montag bis Freitag,
von 7 Uhr morgens bis 18 Uhr abends.
Yeah.
Es war ein Lebenstraum:
Seit ich 20 war,
wollte ich mein eigenes Haus bauen.
Ich will mich nicht beklagen.
Es ist das Beste,
was ich je gemacht habe.
Du machst das gut.
- Ja.
Schön, dazusitzen
und mir beim Arbeiten zuzusehen.
Ja, das Beste überhaupt.
Ich komme in Schwitzen.
* Lachen *
Wir brauchen eine Pause.
Hoppla.
Willkommen in Schweden. Skol.
- Thank you.
Cheers.
- Cheers.
Bald sind die Gedanken
wieder bei Tochter Noya,
die in der Schweiz geblieben ist.
Das war das Härteste,
was ich je gemacht habe.
Of course.
Es weckt schlechte Gefühle
und man fühlt sich sehr schuldig.
Wir können sie
auch von hier aus gut unterstützen.
Du kannst jeden Tag
mit ihr sprechen.
Per Flugzeug
bist du in 2 Std. bei ihr.
Es ist auch
ein Schritt ins Erwachsenenleben.
Sie muss jetzt
auf sich selber aufpassen.
Sie macht grosse Fortschritte.
Ich bin sehr stolz auf sie.
Sie macht es toll.
Für seine grosse Liebe
hält der 50-Jährige noch eine
ganz besondere Überraschung bereit.
Wie cool ist das denn?
- Das ist für uns.
How cool is this?
Ein Privatstrand. Ginger,
du hast einen eigenen Strand.
Das ist unser kleines Paradies.
Oh my God.
Ich kenne den Mann,
dem hier fast alles gehört.
Ich kaufte ein Boot und fragte ihn,
ob ich den Platz benützen dürfe.
Er sagte: "Ja, klar."
Ginger!
In der nächsten Folge
von "Hin und weg"
können Jamal und Romain
die Ankunft ihres Leihmutterbabys
kaum erwarten.
Das ist das erste Ultraschallbild,
das wir erhalten haben.
Bei der Familie seines Bruders
kann sich Jamal
auf die neue Rolle vorbereiten.
* Er macht Fliegergeräusche. *
In Schweden wird Niklas
zum medizinischen Notfall.
Sie haben mich notoperiert.
Kurz vor dem Durchbruch.
Auf Bali entwirft Monica
gediegene Inneneinrichtungen
für den internationalen Markt.
Hindu Dewa will mit dem Tempeltanz
den Göttern eine Freude bereiten.
Du musst dich
mit den Göttern verbinden.
Dann geht es wie von selbst.
Wie eine Meditation.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023